hello and welcome to this video playing
I am ha gay there we go yeah I can
actually use my no it's not playing
Bishop b5 now and what I had recommended
in my video against 1 p-3 but it didn't
happen he is deviating from his usual
stuff and plates you for instead of his
normal we should be five okay so we got
this reversed Sicilian happen let's see
if I if we can get something interesting
going here just develop him hmm i don't
know if i should play a 6 or not here
maybe I should have gone a 5 at some
point anyway not a big deal I hope
ok
don't sure why g3 was was cleaning was
essential okay going back I can go to
have six also not sure where to go as
idea was to fight for the e4 square here
there's some merit to this idea clearly
but I have some ideas myself on d4
here here for is something that is
rather tempting after he's not taking on
f5 makes a this whole night to g5 look a
little bit weird
okay but how do I continue him I can go
age 65 even but that looks that looks
risky don't think I should involve the
Jeep on there with the bishop being
won't be too and age six is also wow
what now it's that that that note that
cannot be good I don't believe it not
one bit i'm sorry mr. Hogg a um k let's
do this okay Nyjah force even a move may
I just prevent hope she warned him
forgot about that I somebody forgot
about the move okay come on I'll
sacrifice something cannot go back now
anyway how unnecessary anyway it's still
kind of interesting night takes h2s idea
after his night move from f3 and I have
my doubts that this actually works
objectively speaking but it's still kind
of interesting I have my doubts because
of the of the combination of G Fallon
[ __ ] won't be to some night f3 is
probably probably defending here just
preventing Queen to h4 how can I can
take the rook actually maybe this is
playable very weird stuff though okay so
you have to take the rook I don't like
to do that but just for tempe and how do
i how do i get stuff on his King it
takes to the night Wow
never expect any movie I'm night h five
or six stuff runs into 95 immediately
okay that wasn't so bad it covers it
covers his position also
well that's really bad when I played
that well I move like age six is
absolutely terrible to play but i have
to i think i have to play stuff like
that oh my goodness
really awful okay that I'm not too
unhappy about
material wise are not saw in such bad
shape ending would be okay i think but
you want you will not trade that would
be really enter positional
yeah maybe I can take it for I don't see
at the mood why I cannot take it it
feels like it shouldn't work but I don't
see why okay time morning
I can take 9 p-7 I have rugby aid now
maybe not okay all 98 I cannot play ok
let's keep this stuff for the moment
it's not easy to play
okay i think the worst the worst should
be 0 in this position
and he also has no time check white for
Vince on time Wow now I wasn't I mean
here I think it was a real decision that
he allowed f4 don't really believe in
that very much but something bad happens
around here ok Knight g4 was strong that
night you from or was it wrong because I
now threatened this and he has a yes I
cannot move the F porno adds a fantastic
position I get lube takes a fine this is
the best line and this is totally bad
for white okay and this well this isn't
so great really isn't now here I have to
take be to just take me to this and I'm
in excellent shape this is very good and
yeah I just I just didn't really cd4
okay it's not working due to Knight
takes Knight takes this could end Bishop
takes Bishop takes Knight takes and this
this is actually working for black with
a good position taking us losing check
I has to play something like that but
now after this this and some g 5 i'm ok
yeah there's no bishop that's a great
difference ok and this shouldn't work
yeah he can actually go Rupe 21 what I
what I feared but yeah this 95 is
killing his he is getting there first
this is not a double check he can take
the Queen ok so on this and now he took
with the night which looked weird and I
should just take you for ok because that
forces the Queen trade very bad very bad
him and now he's much much better as I
as I thought and tonight h4 was winning
the whole time and again nie Dage form T
I'm me energy 5s winning 95 take screen
Teague's cannot prevent that oh my
goodness i was i was more than lucky
then in this game here it's the first
time for a long while that i'm not
losing a laughter g6 now now i'm winning
and everything is kind of protected and
he has not taken all those all those
chances i was a very lucky win poor okay
thanks for watching